تنطلق هذه الصواريخ برؤوسها النوويه تعبر
القارات وتسابق نفسها في حجم الدمار الذي
تحدثه وبين الحلم والاخر تطلق كوريا
الشماليه عنان قوتها البالستيه وان كان
اخرها تحت ستار قمر صناعي بحسب كل من
امريكا وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان
يشتد الوضع خطوره مع كل تجربه تجريها
فتهز قلق الدول الثلاث لترد بسرب طائرات
وتدريبات مشتركه لتبدو هذه البلدان مصطفى
معا اكثر من اي وقت مضى ضد كوريا الشماليه
اجتماعات متتاليه من قمه كمبوديا الثلاثيه
لبحث هيئه تشاوريه للردع الى سنغافوره
لتعزيز جهودهم ضدما اسموه تقاسم تحذيرات
برامج كوريا الشماليه
اتفاق مع عدم ارتقبا مع تاكيد وكاله
يونهاب الكوريه الجنوبيه اقرار الثلاثي
بتشكيل منظومه معلوماتيه للصد تحسبا من اي
صاروخ قد تطلقه بيونج نظام معلوماتي يرجو
التحالف ان يدشنه قبل نهايه عام 2023
وذلك من اجل تحسين قدره كل دوله على
اكتشاف وتقييم الصواريخ التي يتم اطلاقها
ووفق المعلومات الاوليه ستربط الدول انظمه
مشاركه المعلومات احدها يتم تشغيله بين
كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده والاخر
بين اليابان وامريكا سيسمح النظام اذا
بتبادل بيانات انظمه الرادار والقياده
والسيطره بين الجيوش وبالتالي يشكل هيكلا
دفاعيا صاروخيا اقليميا واسعا
تفاصيل عمليه ما زالوا يبحثونها لتفعيل
تلك الاليه قريبا
لمواجهه صواريخ يصفونها بالمهدده للامن
والاستقرار العالميين اسراء الصغير
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات